uh okay
so i'm giving you uh techniques that we
like to use uh with i o um in security
security proofs so another useful trick
is uh extraction
so often obfuscation and extraction can
be sort of the enemies of each other
but
there is sort of a particular case where
where that's actually not true
so let me just say how we the strategy
that we want to um
invoke when we use it um
so i might want to say that uh the ios
of a program and a punctured version of
the program
are actually indistinguishable even
though they obviously don't have the
same functionality because one is
punctured and one is not
so there's some differing input t
but otherwise they're the same
and then the strategy is to show that
t is uh
hard to you know it's hard to find t
so maybe in that case you can say that
the ios of these two things are
indistinguishable
and then i'll do the usual thing and try
to argue that the punctured version of
uh
the program uh doesn't have i mean it
lacks the value of pft which the
adversary needs for its attack
there's
yeah so i mean you're going to lose
when you're going to pay for it in your
reduction and if you try to do it too
many times then
at some points clearly it will be
distinguishable because half the program
will be punctured and
you can easily tell the difference
okay so there's this notion of a
differing input obfuscation which just
relates to which is
the defined way
um security is that for every uh
distinguisher in the dio game there's an
extractor that extracts a differing
input
okay so that's uh what we say for
security
dio implies io because there is no
differing input
okay so there can't be an extractor that
extracts a differing input
okay
um
what i'm going to show here is that if
it happens to be the case that two
programs differ on say only one input
um
then in that case you will actually be
able to extract the the
differing input if if you have an i o
distinguisher
in other words i o implies dio in the
particular case where there's only
uh there's an actual extractor that will
extract the one point at which they
differ
so um
does that make sense
try to explain it again
so so again what we want to prove
the concept of dio the security
definition
is that
if there's a distinguishing between two
programs you obfuscate two programs
which don't have the same functionality
and what i want to say is that if i
apply my obfuscator to this program
and and there's a distinguisher then i
then i can actually take that
distinguisher and figure out an input at
which they differ
okay so that's the concept of dio that
this is an extraction algorithm
that extracts a differing input are you
going to show how to extract
yes
so yeah maybe that makes things easier i
should just go
show how you extract
so so then what i want to say here is
that let's just suppose that i apply my
indistinguishability obfuscator to two
programs that differ at one input
what happens
right i don't immediately have any
guarantee just from io
but what i want to say
is that
if there's a distinguisher for io i can
use that distinguisher to locate the
input at which they differ
i can pull out that value of t at which
they differ
and then if i can secondarily argue that
for some reason this value of t should
be hard to find
uh well then i can argue that i o
implies
that um
but that even though these programs have
different functionality
the their obfuscations are
indistinguishable
i'm not saying if there is io then there
is dio you're saying that same i o is
also at the i o without changing the
construction
if there is i o there is dio for
programs that differ at only say one
input right but this vio is the same as
i yes it's just the same exact program
number of inputs
so so you lose in the reduction so let
me let me describe this and and you can
kind of see how
it becomes problematic if there are lots
of differing inputs so i have a question
uh it's like the last sentence you wrote
that
the work of the extract skills within a
number of different it is somehow
counterintuitive that if circuits differ
at large number of places it should be
easier to look at the differing inputs
rather than this is this a manifestation
of the proof techniques or
it's something of a fact
um let me try to describe on the next
slide and then i'll try to think about
what happens when you have more
okay
so let's suppose you have two programs
uh that are the same except at t
okay
so i can create sort of lots of
in-between programs
uh that for each k it it behaves like
the first program up to input k
and then after that it behaves like the
second program
so for all k less than t the program p
sub k is is equivalent
to the first program
after that it becomes equivalent to the
second program
so you have these two clusters of
programs
okay io says that the programs in this
cluster are indistinguishable
obscurations in the
second cluster you also have
indistinguishability
so if there's some uh you know big
distinguisher between the endpoints then
uh then obviously uh you can
sort of distinguish between programs in
the two clusters
and in particular you can just use
binary search to locate the point at
which uh it crosses over
so if you have uh 10 differing inputs so
so if there's just one i can argue that
the gap between here and here is really
big you know it's basically as big as
the gap between the endpoints in terms
of distinguishing ability
right
it's a really strong i o scheme
if you have 10 different clusters
of programs
then if i have an i o distinguisher that
succeeds with probability epsilon
it's going to sort of distinguish
between neighboring clusters with
probability epsilon over 10 or something
like that
right so the
so if you have tons of differing inputs
it
you know
between neighboring clusters the
distinguishing probability is going to
be very small it's going to become
smaller and smaller relative to the
original success probability of the io
distinguisher
and so
even though there are many more
differing inputs
somehow the fact that the epsilon
is smaller
could make it more difficult to use some
sort of binary search to to locate
a particular point that's when there are
many more but still negligibly small
numbers if half the inputs are different
you just choose an input at random and
find it
uh right so i guess i mean there's some
yeah
so this sort of works when the number of
differing inputs is small but it's uh
i mean io doesn't apply dio in general
because this doesn't uh necessarily
scale to all sorts of
parameter regimes
well one thing is this this phenomena
that when there are many values it's
harder to find them is actually not
unique to this i mean think of
optimization problem when there's a
single optimum then you can use greedy
to get there easily when there are many
it's harder it's not a unique thing for
people
so you're showing a reduction you want
to say that
if there is a distinguisher who can tell
the two programs apart then you can find
like you know an extractor so
i'm just trying to see what the
extractor will lose the extractor gets
uh
what these two programs right the fusion
of those two programs
so he has to work to skate intermediate
programs
like you said himself but then he needs
to test the success probability i mean
it doesn't look like completely like a
trivial i mean
yeah so depending on his original
success probability might have to
you know do lots of iterations
this side program so he has like you
know just one sample of these two
programs
and he has to find uh or
i just want to
it seems like the reduction has to be
somewhat non-trivial you need to be able
to test that you can distinguish and
things like that yeah you need to sort
of run it many times and so it basically
you know
so that he can distinguish which cluster
he's in he might have to his probability
is low he might have to do it many times
yeah
the success probability
of the distinguisher has taken over only
the coins of the distinguisher or also
over the obfuscation the randomness and
obfuscation
um
is both
yeah
you give a sub-exponential i o
do you get this for super quality
for some super quality yes so you're
asking some does sub-exponential i o
imply dio or
or maybe not full-blown
yeah so if so for some super poly
it works for some parameter regimes and
others not i mean you just
have to make sure that you don't
lose some factor that you know breaks
one of the components of the
scheme
so yeah if all the primitives they use
are you know greater than the number of
differing points then you're probably
okay
it goes up to some
it's not just one point i mean you can
use it beyond one point but
it doesn't work for all parameters
okay so now i want to claim that if i uh
puncture a program at just some random
input
that it's going to be hard to find that
okay
so let's give some particular code to my
punctured program
pt
let's uh suppose that f is a one-way
function and i define y to be f of t
so
uh so the particular code that i'm going
to give my program is is that
let's let it be an injective when we
function
is that uh if
f of x happens to equal this value y
which it only does for t
then i'm going to output bot
and otherwise i'll uh run the program p
okay so that's that's
that's the program p puncture to t okay
it just happens to have some weird
conditional in there
uh but uh
but clearly um
you know this t should be hard to find
if f is a one-way function right
so assuming i o and and one-way
functions
what we get from the binary search
algorithm before
is is that you shouldn't be able to
locate this point and and that uh
the i o of the two programs should be
indistinguishable for a random
puncturing
okay does that make sense
so you can get sort of a circular
security from this so if you happen to
have like uh so here's a big big cycle
um
so
so one application of these sort of key
cycles where you have
you know secret key encrypted under the
next public key is fhe
um
where you know these key cycles are
if you have a key cycle you can do
unbounded computation homomorphically
so um
but i'm going to make this a really big
key cycle because what i want to do is
make this key cycle so big that i can
embed a one-way function
into this
this domain
okay
but of course if the key cycle is that
big i can't write it down so uh so what
i do is i provide an obfuscation that
provides random access to the key cycle
that outputs
on input it outputs the public public
key
and
the related encrypted secret key
what i want to argue here is that you
know if you have a start off with a
semantically secure encryption scheme
and you
also provide this key cycle it's still
semantically secure
you have to put uh
some prfs in there yeah you know
punctured prf
i think i'll show on the next slide
the particular code for this
okay so
now i just want to use the argument
before that if this this domain is large
if the space of possible t's is big
enough
i can just puncture this program at a
random point t and it should be hard to
distinguish
the obfuscation of that program from the
obfuscation of the original one
right
but if i do that if i puncture it i've
destroyed this delicate structure of the
cycle
there's no cycle anymore
and once there's no cycle i can i can
basically rely on semantic security and
some some hybrid arguments blah blah
blah
to show that i can just sort of unravel
this whole key cycle and replace it with
a bunch of
nonsense
okay so uh
so this for this to work as i said
before the domain of the you know places
i can the size of this key cycle has to
be exponential
so that it supports an injective one-way
function
only functions are the previous called
category function i don't see a letter
wrap on this slide
yeah no that was just this uh
this proof before and that i used
so
um
so just
use it just in general for any program
if if the space of inputs is big enough
uh to support an injective one-way
function
if i puncture it at a random point then
it will be hard to
distinguish
so you think this is a so because here i
see the i have written on the next slide
i don't see the letter i've written you
just
i'm i'm
no i mean i'm just i mean the particular
you don't see any code at all really for
for this uh for this um function that
i'm obfuscating
this program's functionality i can embed
some code in it that has uh has the
function f in it if i wanted or well at
least when i when i punctured i could
put
the same
code that i had before here
so you have to store the exponential
number of keys
no this provides random access to the to
the key cycle
but this program has to have all the
keys right
yes which it'll generate using some well
maybe i should provide the code for
for
so here's some some sample code for for
p
is exponential
well i like it for aesthetic reasons
because if you have an um if you have a
key cycle then you can do unbounded fhe
even for this
you just you don't i mean it's kind of
weird because yeah to get it for the
actual legitimate evaluator to go all
the way around you would have to do you
know an exponential amount of work but i
just aesthetically i like that you can
have an actual
key cycle so that in principle you can
do uh
unbounded computation
even if the second is so loud no because
you will never get to it right i mean
i'll keep going whenever i'll keep going
no i i i did not i have the same
question can you answer it again
i didn't understand what it says whether
this means that i o together with
bounded fhe gives unbounded methods yeah
i would say yes but really you don't
even need the circular security for it
because you can just have
not even a cycle but just like an
obfuscated program like i showed you
before
but just that just provides a super
polynomial number of encrypted secret
keys so you don't technically like to
need the cycle i i like the cycle
personal preference
yeah so i mean this is a um
denote and uh various other people they
have exactly this thing here
to get
uh pure fhe from from uh leveled fhas
just they don't provide the full cycle
because you don't
actually need it
there's circular security some
assumption that is made in many places
like efficiency are you saying this
assumption in general can be replaced by
io for some reason we think io is a
better assumption than circular security
then we get this or is it only for
circular security with exponential
cycles
it's only for exponential cycles so if i
have some other result that
assumes circular security i cannot
automatically say well
no definitely not and in fact
this result is kind of funny i
it's kind of provocative actually
because there are results showing that
io uh doesn't imply circular security
for cycles that are small
essentially in the in the obfuscated
program
you you have inside there
uh
like all the different secret keys of
the public keys and the obfuscator just
checks
whether the encryptions that it receives
are are correspond to a key cycle
it doesn't mean the dial doesn't imply
security doesn't mean that our skills
are secure
but he's saying i implies that every
scheme is circular secure with
exponentially winning cycles right
yeah there's a couple provisos that i'll
have in the next slide but basically
yeah
okay so the providers that i need are
that uh public keys and ciphertext looks
pseudorandom
but otherwise yeah
okay so here's the particular code um
for um this the sophisticated program
that generates uh encrypted secret keys
right i mean it generates the randomness
um
using a prf
you know it has to it has to do this for
two for
the ice key and i i plus one key right
so it does this
twice you know it generates two key
pairs
and it constructs the encryption of a
secret key i plus 100 pki
using randomness
from the prf
then it outputs the
publicate secret key
okay so you can compare this to a
different world that just generates
random junk
uh where essentially all these uh
there are no where there are no secret
keys anymore
and essentially the public keys and the
cipher decks that are supposed to be
output there are just generated directly
from uh from a prf that i mean there's
no secret key anymore right
okay
um so yeah so in this case it's uh
cpa
and i claim that these two worlds are
indistinguishable where i increment
um
the transition point from from u to u
plus one so i i
you know i snip something and then i'm
just going to go around the circle and
replace everything of junk and i just
want to argue that
i can do the
step that corresponds to replacing the u
or u plus swamp uh
key in ciphertext with uh junk
okay
just go around the cycle um
so i
i've already shown you the first part
which is snipping the cycle
um
okay so now
so the first step is that i'm just going
to hardwire the output for u plus one
i can always do that
okay
it's i o security
um
and then at that point i can uh puncture
the prf key at u plus one
because i'm not using it anywhere
okay i mean recall that the code
um
needed stuff for both
i and i plus 1 but that's still not a
problem
because i've already heard i've already
dealt with u
and at this stage i'm dealing with the
new plus one so i can puncture the prf
key there
and so that's fine that's i o security
okay
and then finally i can just
once the key is punctured here i can
just argue pseudorandomness of you know
pprf security and also the
pseudo-randomness of the ciphertext in
the public key to say that i can go here
and just
just generate
the output for u plus one just in a
pseudo-random way according to um
according to that that other program
that i defined on the previous page
which generates the public key and
ciphertext just
pseudorandomly without any secret key
that kind of makes sense
you're not using this extractor thing at
all like this random punctuator is
undetectable you're not using random
punctures right so i just use that in
the first step to argue that i could
puncture
the first step
yeah so i yeah i mean if i completed
this proof i would have to sort of
explain to you why it makes a difference
that there's not a cycle anymore once
i've once i punctured but
i'm kind of omitting some details but
but eventually when you get to the end
of this thing it's
there's no extra secret key lurking
about that you have to worry about
because there's been that snip
but the thing about this
you know cycle like random failures and
yet but just i'm just trying to see if i
want to use it
uh the uses that it's okay to puncture a
problem at a random point as long as
there is exponential set of points
or something like that um
so you can just use it like box and you
don't need to mention other functions or
anything like one-way permutation
anything like that
okay so yeah as
i mentioned these guys did exactly the
same thing got
what what i'll call almost pure fhe from
level that fiji they didn't do the whole
full loop because you don't really need
it
these guys had sort of a
sort of a similar
thing
and like i said that you know i did this
to be a little provocative because for
small cycles uh
um
io can can
can break security i mean it's not
necessarily secure
i o implies that yeah so the question
read inside the parentheses part yeah so
the question is whether ncpa implies
security circular security
um io implies that for small cycles it
does not
for cycles that are small enough that
you can put that that whole cycle into
the uh obfuscated program
but as i said for big cycles i don't
know if you care or not but you know for
big cycles that's that's
not true
so small cycles with a polynomial size
cycles
it doesn't apply in the sense that benny
said before right or as a complexion you
can construct it to counter example
one specific account
it's not like complexity-wise it might
imply
yeah you construct the
what you give in the public key is
additionally an obfuscation of something
that has this the secret keys embedded
in it and that
that obfuscation just tests whether
uh you're giving it a key if
you're giving a key cycle and if it does
and then it outputs all the secret keys
the same
encryption scheme the fact that it's
semantically healed does not mean that
it's so classical it does not mean that
you cannot construct one from the other
it just means that the same one
so
what what is the word arbitrary in the
second one
arbitrary polynomial
i guess yeah
not arbitrary arbitrary
actually what happens when
you restrict yourself to a small cycle
but when the complexity of the
encryption is even smaller than that you
know so a cycle of size and square will
the size of the ciphertext event or the
size of the public keys and or something
like that
why should it make any difference well
at least the negative example you can
stick it in
so
again for the
the first one
cpa does nothing like social security
issues so is this about
not every
ncpa inclusion
is that something that we didn't know
before
yeah for long key cycles it's
non-trivial to prove if it's an actual
loop where you encrypt the you know
there's one one key and you encrypt the
secret key under that public key it's
it's easier to prove but
for a long key cycle you have lots of
different keys and it's kind of it's
non-trivial to prove that some problem
arises
what else can we prove it under other
than i only i o
uh as far as i know since this is a
recent result
so this first result
it's
it's kind of weird it's like there is
this hidden that knows all the keys so
it just shows how given i don't know any
lfh how to construct a very particular
thing where the key generator controls
all the keys so the keys are not
independently generated right i'm just
trying to understand it's uh in what way
is it almost
your fhe or you're saying you construct
one scheme to this extra interface
and this
to argue is
you know everything is fine now that
it's actually a secure or something like
that
so in both ways totally it's like in
those way you construct something very
specific a very specific counter example
and very specific positive result right
i'm not sure in which way is a
or i mean because you pretend it's like
small cycles there's big cycles
to me it doesn't matter both of them
could be the same cycle of length fight
is just one as a you know specific skin
which is bad and the other specific skin
which is good or maybe i'm missing the
is it right
um
it's not that big they're so small it's
just in both case there is a specific
scheme
like one specific scheme one specific
scheme they put again for you know cycle
of life i mean i'm taking an arbitrary
essentially an arbitrary symmetrically
secure encryption scheme here oh all
right well
are you saying that io
implies that ncpa implies circular
security for exponential size cycles
yeah
right i think that's maybe
that this is like this negative result
is the opposite of it is true for
exponential
no i mean the question is what do you
mean by this circular secure with
exponentially sized size
yeah so that's a bit of a problem you
can't write down the cycle so
but if you get the cycle in this
implicit form then it's still secure
so craig do you have the
use of the explanation
not really so maybe i should go to the
next application which is trapdoor
permutation which was
actually a very nice application of
essentially the same idea
or really this is where i i sort of
noticed that you could apply the same
idea to key cycles
so we all know and love trap door
permutations
and we have
on the one hand and on the other hand we
have these multi-linear maps and
obfuscation schemes which seem like a
mess and would
shouldn't allow something uh so perfect
and diamond like as a trapdoor
permutation
um
but it turns out that the uh
it does allow
that uh so um
so uh botansky panath and wix
uh define the the following chapter
permutation i'm going to have
nodes
and what i want is in a permutation is
that i can go from the eighth note to
the i plus one node
right i mean that's basically all the
functionality i want i mean it doesn't
have to
you know this is going to be a very
sparse
subset of the overall space but who
cares i just want something where i can
go forward and not backward right
and i also want something that samples
from the from the domain so but you know
don't worry about that
so anyway so these are the nodes in
their trapdoor permutation which is just
uh index i and prf evaluated at i
and then to uh so that i can go in the
forward direction i provide an
obfuscation
which takes uh input
detects whether it has the correct form
it is in fact the i node for some i and
if so
it outputs the i plus one node
that's their entire trapdoor permutation
we would want the opposite
like we would want i o from travel
implementations why would you want to
build
we had no even heuristic candidate for
one-way permutation that resists the
quantum of that no candidate
i see
based on factoring right there is only
one candidate so this is like the second
candidate i guess
a little more than what we had
but your family is good
okay
um
so i just want to remark that you can
actually view these uh
these nodes as as being secret keys in
in the previous
key cycle that i described and to go
from one node to the next you obfuscate
a program that outputs an encrypted
secret key and the secret key that you
have allows you to decrypt the next and
create the secret key so you can go
forward in the
network so that's kind of the analogy or
connection between these two
so but forget all that and forget about
the sampling for the trapdoor
permutation you also need some out way
to sample
random nodes
for it to be kind of useful for
applications and they have something
they have an algorithm that outputs a
pseudorandom node
all right but uh so i want to prove the
security of the this thing and it's just
basically the same as before i want to
prove that i can't do an inverse
and the way they show it just is exactly
that as before i punctured
the obfuscation at a random point
it's not a cycle anymore
and once there's a cycle essentially you
know there's no way to go all the way
around
to u minus one
that's sort of all i'm going to say
about it i'm not going to go through the
hybrids
but it's basically the same
same idea
is it required is it enough that the io
is polynomially hard
uh
let's see for this uh
i think no
because i i think they have to
um
they have to actually they actually i
think they actually have to
i'm not completely sure because i didn't
go through all the details but i think
they actually have to puncture
or break the links at a lot of these
points maybe
this this t is not entirely random in
the entire cycle but it's random and
sort of close to the uh
to the u
and there you have to be able to do
enough hybrids here between these two
points that's because we you still need
the sampling algorithm so that's that's
the subtlety there yeah able to sample
those points
how does the sampling algorithm sample
the right point the points are very
sparse and if you just help with prg
it's
yeah so it's pseudorandom it's not
random oh there is a there is a yo
around it
something sorry if you just
the can you show the sampling algorithm
on the previous oh there is a yo over
here
okay so um so that line of work cutter
kind of started with potassium penet and
rose and they had uh there's they proved
that uh
finding um a nash
equilibrium is hard
uh assuming i o and sub-exponential
one-way functions
so basically
for nash equilibrium is pbad complete
pbad is this problem of
basically you're given a succinct
program that
allows you to
you know go forward or backward
there's some some graph underlying graph
where in degree and out degree is at
most one
and you're given some compact program on
this exponential size program that
graph that allows you to go forward and
backward and the question is whether you
can find you start off at a source node
you're given that and the question is
whether you can find some other source
or sync note
and they just
do something similar they um they snip
the line
at a random point
and once it's snipped
basically
the other source and sync nodes are
going to become inaccessible
just using this program where it's where
that part has been removed
okay so i had a you know i planned sort
of like a i don't know four hour talk or
something so
so uh
i want to give you some idea of the
scope so that was kind of the techniques
and i want to give you some idea of just
like everything that's been done
uh using a distinguishability
obfuscation just so you have some idea
of of of the scope of it
let me say one thing let's not aim for
the four hours
four hours do whatever you have in your
time and i do want to hope to have
a completion of these talks at some
later point
so
i don't feel that we need the rest of
the two hours in the next seven minutes
yeah i suspected i wouldn't get to this
but um i just want to give you some that
a lot of stuff has been done using i o
okay and i thought it would be fun to
sort of group it by area in our boot
camp
you know so fhe multi-linear maps
delegation
multiplayer computation grappled
circuits ram differential privacy all
right
so i'm just going to sort of state the
results because obviously at this point
i can't really do much more
you can get fhe
from
i o
in a public key encryption scheme that
is re-randomizable
okay so that basically means you can
take
an encryption of some value you can
produce
from via the re-randomization process
and perfectly random encryption of that
same value if you have a randomizable
public key encryption scheme and an io
then you get fhe
intuitively
i don't know i mean there's not really
any noise uh the role that it plays is
in um
is in the security proof
where um
you know i mean you can probably read
this right so
um
they're going to be a lot of hybrids in
this security proof and in particular
what basically what the scheme is going
to do is going to take two input cipher
texts it's going to decrypt them form
the nand output of ciphertext
okay and then we're going to do hybrids
over like all possible pairs of
ciphertexts that's a lot of hybrids
that's what these js are
so
you have to be able to do a lot you have
to do hybrids over all these cipher
decks okay
so we can boost the i o security and ppr
security so that that's still not a
problem we can you know we can still
it's kind of independent of the
encryption scheme we can still
do hybrids over all the possible cipher
texts even if you know
um
just because it's kind of independent
uh the problem is that there's also this
step
um
where you need to argue that
the outputs of the obfuscated program
are
are indistinguishable here
and this part of this hybrid has really
it has more to do with the encryption
scheme itself it's not like
based on the i o or punctured prf it's
something it's a statement about the
encryption scheme and when you're doing
uh an exponential you know so if l is
the length of the ciphertext and you're
doing two to the l hybrids over
um the encryption scheme that's kind of
a problem
right but it's not a problem if this is
statistically randomizable
okay so you get perfect
indistinguishability here you don't have
to worry about any
parameter issues in the encryption
scheme
where it comes up but there's no noise
in the scheme per se it's just
it doesn't have much connection at all
to previous fhe schemes
okay so that's fhe uh
multilinear maps there's uh
just kind of a positive result that uh
an obfuscation of this program which um
basically exponentiates by some hidden
value um
and it sort of sort of performs you know
a multi-linear map type functionality
inside the obfuscated program
um
it's it's still not it's not very
satisfying
this scheme
basically because i mean you can't
really combine given sort of an
obfuscation for one that has an x inside
it and one that has a y inside it you
can't really combine them to get an
obfuscation that has x and y inside it
right i mean you can sort of multiply by
x and y and the exponents separately
that's useful for some things like key
agreement where you want to get product
to the exponents
of the different guys
but it's not sort of a general
multi-linear map
in the fullest sense
that's kind of cool
delegation i talked about uh constrained
signatures it's kind of useful for
delegation i don't really have much more
to say about i o and delegation it seems
like they're kind of better
solutions
you know yell talk about her
there is this paper uh um
by emit and others
but i mean you could consider sort of a
more challenging type of delegation
where i want to outsource my entire
you know uh complicated web service to
uh to an untrusted platform and so they
they sort of deal with that more
complicated situation so maybe the
advantage of i o here is just in the
types of
you know more complex types of
delegation you can achieve
um
so there are applications of i o to mpc
the ones that i think are most
interesting are getting a two-round
adaptively secure npc
line of works there um
and there's this a second uh work that
shows that you can get that that
addresses the communication complexity
of mpc
so what if you have a function you want
to do secure function evaluation where
the function has extremely long output
much much longer than the inputs say
so what then is the communication
complexity of secure function evaluation
in this setting can you say that it's
sublinear in the output size of the
function that would that would be nice
because in the insecure case
it is sublinear right
uh so they show that the answer is yes
i kind of wanted to go over this and
kind of not it's kind of complex um
so the way you get adaptively secure mpc
is that uh it sort of builds on deniable
encryption and
uh which sahayan waters did in the
original scheme
deniable encryption has an algorithm
that allows you to explain
some you know some value that's been
generated
you have an explain algorithm that
generates randomness that is consistent
with some value in the uh in the mpc
protocol and that's kind of useful for
getting adaptive security
okay so there's just some way using io
and punctured prfs
that just magically
i can take a value where i don't know
how it was generated but i can i can use
this explain algorithm to get randomness
that explains how you know how it was
generated it's not the same randomness
that was actually used it's just some
kind of trapdoor
randomness that comes out with this
explainer
okay
um
that's basically all i wanted to go over
i mean there's just tons of uh
applications uh
you can sort of look at them
um
okay
let's just see if i missed anything oh i
wanted to uh just just mention just one
minute
um
that bootstrapping i o so i described
one way to get i o for general circuits
from i o for uh for nc one circuits
a second way that has been done to do
that is to use randomized encodings so
you obfuscate a program that's going to
output a randomized encoding that that
you know
a grappled circuit that
that you can then run
uh so this doesn't need fhe to uh to
bootstrap i o so it's a
it's a different technique you just need
basically punctured prfs and all the all
the usual stuff
better than nc one so there's benny
again
he's he's doing both randomized
encodings and vbb did this originally
for showed how to do this for vbb but
now we know how to do this for i o
so not only circuits have been done but
we have i o for ram computations
i don't
know myself the full details of all
these but it looks like it's been pretty
much done everything is succinct in
every way you could possibly imagine
in terms of the ram programs i mean
you know the i o is the size of the
program the you know everything's
everything is nice and succinct
differential privacy there's kind of a
love hate relationship between i o and
differential privacy on the one hand it
might be able to help in certain
situations
to uh
you know so if you want to use
differential privacy to handle like a
a very diverse set of queries you might
need to add more noise than you would
like
whereas functional encryption might
allow you to sort of
do this individually for different types
of queries and so you have to add less
noise
at each step
so so if i have a function that i i want
a researcher to be able to evaluate on
the database
i would uh submit that function to the
government he would provide me with a
key a function function encryption
private key
that evaluates the function on the
encrypted data and then adds a little
noise to the result so that it's
sanitized enough
so i don't know the full details but
essentially
there's the possibility there that you
have to add less noise because it's it's
individualized for each function
on the other hand there's um
trader tracing which is kind of the
enemy of differential privacy and we
have very efficient uh trader tracing
schemes from
io
which has implications for differential
privacy
okay
can we say the final results when
financial privacy works i mean how they
say oh sorry what's the punchline for
the financial privacy
i i don't have the actual like
parameters of the trader tracing scheme
and what exactly that applies for them
and so you get
stronger hardness results for
differential events
yeah so i essentially the idea in
differential privacy is you want to
summarize data so that you don't reveal
anything about the individual
the the goal of trade tracing is
precisely the opposite
use different
pirate decoders can't be
summarized in a way that
hides
you should be able to pick out a
particular individual
right there are more results on
complexity theory there's also water
marking there was a negative result in
the original obfuscation paper for sort
of perfect obfuscators that exactly
preserve the functionality but they only
approximately preserve it
and approximately can even be you know
an overwhelming fraction
you can get watermarking from i o
you know
various good things for hashing
impossibilities that's it
just
pretty predictable in my case experience
you didn't mention the most practical
application
writing papers
it's actually pretty challenging
any other questions
what's inside these papers that we just
said well i wanted to see the slide on
here little flying